UNCLE JOE WILLING TO GO?
SENIOR ADVISOR FOR TRUMP 2020.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
HOW ARE YOU?
>> THANK YOU.
ABOUT A MONTH.
>> Sean: ABOUT A MONTH.
UNCLE SEAN'S HERE.
YOU SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING.
SHE'S DESPERATE.
SHE'S HANGING BY A THREAD.
JOE, NOT WELL-LIKED, BUT HE
STILL TRYING TO SUCK UP.
WHERE IS THIS GOING TO END UP?
>> IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHERE THE DEMOCRATS WERE,
HERE'S YOUR ANSWER.
JOE BIDEN HAS REALIZED HE HAS
GOT TO MOVE SO FAR TO THE LEFT
TO FIT IN WITH THIS NEW PARTY,
SO PEOPLE GOING TO THE POLL'S IN
2020 SHOULD REMEMBER THIS.
IT'S A   BOCCACCIO CORTEZ IN CHA
IT'S A   BOCCACCIO CORTEZ IN CHG
IT'S A   BOCCACCIO CORTEZ IN CHE
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE, THE GREEN
NEW DEAL PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
CHARGE OF THE PARTY.
SOME SOCIALISTS, WHO WANT TO
TAKE FULL GOVERNMENT CONTROL OF
EVERYTHING IN OUR COUNTRY, OR WE
CAN CONTACT TO CONTINUE THE
INCREDIBLE PROSPERITY WE HAVE
UNDER DONALD TRUMP.
>> Sean: HOW DO YOU RECOVER
FROM I WANT TO ELIMINATE OIL,
GAS, COMBUSTION ENGINE.
TRUMP IS DIFFERENT.
HE RAN ON PROMISES.
HE STUCK TO THEM, AND HE'S DOING
EXACTLY WHAT HE SAID.
>> YEAH, HE HAS DELIVERED ON ALL
THE PROMISES TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, WHICH IS WHY I ALWAYS
SAY THAT I THINK THIS PRESIDENT
WILL EASILY WIN REELECTION.
THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT WE WILL
ARREST A SINGLE MINUTE UNTIL
NOVEMBER 3RD OUT OF 2020.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE.
IT IS A DIRE SITUATION RIGHT
NOW.
THINK IF ANY OF THESE PEOPLE GOT
CONTROL OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHAT THAT WOULD MEAN FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
IT WOULD BE A VERY DIFFERENT
LOOKING COUNTRY.
I HAVE VERY FULL CONFIDENCE THAT
OUR PRESIDENT --
>> Sean: NOBODY SHOWS UP TO
ANY DEMOCRAT RALLIES.
IT'S PRETTY FUNNY.
REALLY, THESE TINY ITSY-BITSY
CROWDS.
THE PRESIDENT'S ENTHUSIASM IS
THERE.
SUPPORT NOT ONLY SEEMS TO BE
HOLDING, BUT STRONGER.
THE QUESTION IS, OKAY, WITH
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT AND THE
BEST EMPLOYMENT SITUATION SINCE
1969, I CAN TELL YOU EVERY MET
THAT WAS ON THE WORLD SERIES
TEAM.
WILL THEY NOW GO OVER TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYING, HE
WORKS.
HE'S GETTING THE JOB DONE.
>> I THINK HE WILL WIN WITH
WOMEN IN A BIGGER WAY,
AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN A BIGGER
WAY, HISPANICS IN A BIGGER WAY.
I THINK MORE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
COME OUT AND VOTE FOR
DONALD TRUMP IN 2020.
IT HAS TO HURT THEM, BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE SICK OF THIS.
THIS IS NOT.
THEY ARE CONTINUING TO STOP THI
THIS.
>> Sean: MELANIA, BARON.
ERIC CAN TAKE IT.
THE ATTACKS AGAINST THE WOMEN IN
YOUR FAMILY HAVE BEEN
UNPRECEDENTED.
>> YEAH, BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS
WOMEN ARE ON OUR SIDE.
WE HAD A BIG LUNCH TODAY.
OUR WOMEN FOR TRUMP COALITION.
IT IS AMAZING.
>> Sean: ONE DO YOU GET OUT?
I GOT A JOB AVAILABLE FOR YOU.
>> JOBS ARE BACK IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
THEY ARE BACK FOR HARDWORKING